sur place Philippe crosser en direct
donc de le vivre bonjour Philippe
l'envoyé spécial daipi cette ville
refuge pour des dizaines de milliers de
déplacés donc relativement épargnés je
le disais jusque là mais ce matin les
Russes ont frappé on frappait fort même
vous en avez été témoin
voilà j'ai entendu quatre explosions ce
matin j'en ai vu quatre et j'ai entendu
clairement le son d'un missile russe qui
qui a donc heurté une de ces cibles et
la fumée noire bien sûr qu'on a vu après
aussi au-dessus de cette ville qui a été
paisible largement paisible jusqu'ici
dans un pays en guerre on a aussi le
premier bilan avec cette mort et 11
blessés selon les autorités locales donc
deux blessés en état grave un enfant
blessé aussi alors quels ont été
cessibles selon les autorités
ukrainiennes ici à le vivre trois cibles
militaires on n'a pas beaucoup plus de
détails c'est assez compréhensible et
ensuite aussi ce qui paraît être une
cible civile c'est un garage de
pneumatique on vient de voir l'endroit
on a vu des douzaines de voitures
brûlées des bâtiments totalement
détruits aussi au-dessus d'une ligne de
train c'est assez intéressant on a vu
passer un train qui venait de la
direction de ni pro C'est dans le centre
plus ou besoin de l'Ukraine très proche
de du don de basse donc probablement des
gens à bord qui sont en train d'évacuer
l'est pour venir à une ville qui
normalement qui dans le passé n'a pas eu
beaucoup d'attaques de frappe de la part
de la Russie cela a changé aujourd'hui
voilà ni pro ou nous envoyer spéciaux
nous nous témoigner d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure sur cette antenne là aussi de
bombardements plus ou moins intense ce
matin faut-il du coup parler aujourd'hui
d'escalade
alors l'escalade passe largement bien
sûr dans l'est du pays mais on se
rappelle de l'avertissement de la part
de Moscou qu'ils allaient
y avoir plus de frappes sur des cibles
et militaires largement dans la capitale
qui est bien sûr il y a bien eu des
frappes sur des cibles militaires dans
les derniers prendre pendant les
derniers 3 jours mais cette ville de le
vivre normalement elle a été épargnée
comme vous venez de le dire mais
aujourd'hui ici aussi donc des cibles
militaires a priori c'est ce que nous
disent les autorités ukrainiennes ont
été touchées ce n'est pas la première
fois par exemple un dépôt de pétrole un
VTT touché dans un endroit juste
derrière moi il y a deux semaines donc
les Russes connaissent ces cibles
militaires aussi dans l'uette dans
l'ouest de l'Ukraine un endroit bien sûr
très très important du point de vue
logistique pour les armes qui arrivent
dans le reste du pays de la part des
pays membres de l'OTAN par exemple mais
c'est aussi bien sûr une ville très
importante du point de vue humanitaire
beaucoup de réfugiés passent par cette
ville pour aller à l'étranger en Pologne
par exemple aussi mais il y avait aussi
beaucoup de monde qui passent par ici
pour rentrer à Kiev bien sûr les
derniers jours merci beaucoup Philippe
crosserand en direct de lui donc pour
nous témoigner de ces frappes